in the last video we evaluated this 4x4
determinant and we found out that it was
equal to seven and the way we did it is
we went down this first row we use the
definition I gave you in the last video
where you use this first row I could
even write it here we said this is equal
to 1 times the determinant of 0 to 0 1 2
3 3 0 0 minus 2 times the determinant
you cross these guys cross that row and
that column out 1 0 2 1 0 2 2 2 0 0 3 0
and then we went to the plus the 3 times
its sub-matrix I don't have to figure
that out if you cross out that row that
column and then minus 4 we just keep
switching the signs times the
determinant of its sub-matrix so this
one has a bunch of terms and this one's
going to have a bunch of terms cross
that row and that column out you get 1 0
2 0 1 2 2 3 0 I'll just write here 1 0 2
0 1 2 2 3 0 and that is a completely
legitimate way to figure out a
determined and that was our definition
for how to find terminate but I want to
show you in this video is that there's
more than one way to solve for
determinate what I'm going to show you
this way is the same thing that we did
down this first row we can actually do
down any row or any column of this
determinant and of this matrix and the
reason why that's useful is because we
can pick rows or columns that have a
unusually large number of zeros because
that tends to simplify our computation
so the first thing that you have to do
before you embark on picking an
arbitrary row or column let's say for
example we want to pick this let's do
one row in one column in this example so
let's say we want to go down that row
instead because we like the fact that it
has a lot of zeros there the first thing
you have to do is remember the pattern
remember you switch signs on the
coefficients and you don't just switch
signs as you go down a row you also
switch signs as you go down a column so
the general pattern for 4 by 4 will look
like this it'll be plus minus plus minus
minus plus minus plus and then you get
what a plus minus minus plus plus minus
minus plus
really this checkerboard pattern if you
wanted to figure out the sign for any IJ
so let's say you wanted to figure out
the sign for you know this is 2 2 so if
you want to find the sign let me write
it this way let's say we have a function
let me define a function and I think the
checkerboard pattern is pretty clear to
you but I'll just write it down so let's
say I wanted to figure out the sign the
sign not the not the trig identity not
the trig ratio I want to figure out the
sine of any entry where you give me an i
and a J what you can do is you just take
negative 1 to the I plus J power so if
you wanted to figure out the sign for
the let's say you are in you are in row
4 column 2 row 4 column 2 so what will
be you do 4 plus 2 1 negative 1 to the 6
power is equal to 1 so that's going to
be a positive positive 1 now if you take
this guy let's say you want to take
let's say you want to take this guy so
this is I is equal to 2 J is equal to J
is equal to 3 you're in the second row
third column 2 plus 3 is 5 minus 1 to
the fifth power is minus 1 and you have
a minus there so that's another way to
think about it but the checkerboard
pattern is pretty straightforward so now
that you have the checkerboard pattern
in your mind let's go down this row
let's go down this row so we start with
the 2 but notice that we have to
multiply it by minus because you go plus
minus plus minus so you have a minus 2
times the determinant of its sub-matrix
so you cross out this row in that column
and you're left with this matrix up here
so it's 2 3 4 0 2 0 1 2 3 and then you
go you this was a minus so then you have
a plus so then you have a plus 3 times
get rid of this guy's column and row and
you have 1 1 0 1 1 0 that's that right
there 3 2 2 3 2 2 and you have 4 0 3 or
0 3 and then
would have a - a zero times its
sub-matrix plus a zero but we can ignore
those because zero times anything is a
zero so already we've simplified our
determinant a good bit so let's see if
we can evaluate this and get the same
number because only then will it be
reasonably satisfying so what's the
determinant of this guy well we can do
it the exact same principle we can go
down any row or column that seems to be
especially simple so let's go down let's
go down that row because that row seems
especially simple so this is going to be
minus 2 that's this minus 2 right here
times the determinant of this guy so the
determinant of this guy we just have to
go and say okay we have a plus and we
have a minus and then we have a plus so
it's going to be minus 0 times its sub
determinant I guess we call it we get
rid of that row and or that column in
that row would be so it'd be minus 0
times anything this is going to be 0
plus 2 so plus 2 times the determinant
get rid of its get rid of its row and
it's column so it's 2 4 1 3 2 4 1 3 and
then you would have a and then you would
have a minus 0 times this thing but who
cares what that is because you have a 0
times it so that just simplified to that
which is nice let me get write it like
that and then you have plus 3 plus 3
times this thing right here let's pick a
nice we don't wanna do the first row we
have no nonzero terms here let's at
least do let me do this row right here
for a little bit of variety
we've none of the columns actually seem
that interesting they all have it at
most one 0 so if we do that one right
here this is a plus minus plus minus
plus so we'll have a plus 0 times 3 4 to
0 we can ignore that minus 2 times the
determinant get rid of this column that
row so 1 I have to be very careful I put
this - there but there wasn't a minus 1
there so let me write it like let me
make sure I want to make sure I don't
make any careless errors right here this
is a plus 1 I was just I just do a minus
1 there to show you how things which
signs so this is going to be a this is
going to be a 3 times so we're going to
go down
this is this three right here I lost my
bearings with that - there but we were
trying to find the determinant of this
so it's a zero times this matrix we
could ignore that - two times its
sub-matrix which is that and that so
it's one one four zero and then you have
a plus three times its sub-matrix one
three one two one three one two just
like that and see if we can simplify
this 2 times 3 is 6 minus 1 times 4 so
this becomes 6 minus 4 so that's 2 so
this whole thing simplifies to 2 times 2
which is 4 4 times minus 2 the whole
thing simplifies to minus 8 now this guy
right here we have 1 times 0 - 0 minus 1
times 4 is minus 4 times minus 2 this
whole thing becomes a positive 8 and you
have 1 times 2 which is 2 minus 1 times
3 which is minus 3 so you had a minus 1
so this becomes a - I mean you get 2
minus 3 minus 1 times 3 so this becomes
a minus 3 so you have an 8 minus a 3 so
this becomes a minus 5 and then you have
a 3 you have a 3 times you have a 3
times a minus 5 right there so 3 times
minus 5 is going to be equal to minus 15
let me make sure I got oh I made a silly
mistake if you have an 8 minus a 3 this
is 8 this is - this is going to be 5
very easy your brain starts to get fried
if you do this long enough and then you
have a 3 times a 5 you get a 15 you get
a 15 and then you have a 15 this term
Plus this term is a 15 - and 8 which is
equal to 7 which lucky for us I barely
evaded making a careless mistake there
we got the right answer but this is a
much simpler computation than we did in
the last video and it was much simpler
because we picked the row that happened
to have a lot of zeros on it so we only
had two of these terms instead of 4
terms like we had
in the last video and you could do the
same you could pick columns that have a
lot of zeros you just have to make sure
that you always use this checkerboard
pattern